the fifth and last one for today is what
we call addition it will look very
similar to this dissection property here
but I want you to look carefully and see
the way in which it is different okay
if I am integrating from A to B and what
I'm integrating is actually not just a
single function but like a bunch of
different functions and I'll give you an
example in a second right so if I'm
integrating not just F let's say I don't
know F and maybe G so if I am
integrating the sum of two functions I'm
adding two functions together with
respect to X okay then I can calculate
this integral sort of like this by
separating out the two functions so I
can say do F first integrate that guy
integrate him separately and then do G
now I said that this would look quite
similar to the dissection property at
least on the face of it it certainly
looks like where you start with one
thing and they end up with two things
can someone tell me what is it that
makes these two properties different
what's the what's the distinction
between them you might see hmm
tell me because I see some of you have
it but not all of you tell me what is it
that allows me to break this into two
pieces what have I changed from the
left-hand side to the right-hand side
I've highlighted for you
I changed the boundaries right I said
okay let's uh let's divide up the
boundaries into two parts okay but if
you look over here at this property the
boundaries remain the same do you notice
that a to be a to be a to be I've
divided up something else
what have I divided so at the moment you
don't have a name for this I guess you
would call it the thing that you're
integrating but this actually has a name
and so I'm going to teach it to you I
doesn't get said very much but if you
see this anywhere now you know what it's
talking about this is called
the integrand it's a great name the
thing that you are integrating the thing
which you are going to search for the
primitive function the thing whose area
underneath the curve you're trying to
evaluate we call that the integral so I
separate out the integrated into its
component pieces and I can say look that
integral that that's some the integral
of a sum is the sum of the integrals
okay and that's kind of very similar if
you think back to differentiation if you
differentiate a function which has like
different pieces to it like this you
guys have been doing this for months now
right all you have to do is excuse me
differentiate the first one and then
differentiate the second so because we
have noticed that differentiation and
integration are kind of like inverse
processes then it shouldn't surprise us
that much that many of the things we can
do with differentiation we can also do
with integration okay so I want to give
you the illustration for this and then
I'm going to set you to work okay so
let's consider the integral from zero to
one of this function okay now I know
because I've given you I've
intentionally given you a very simple
function okay you could just go ahead
and you can work out the primitive by
the way what is the primitive for the x
squared it's X to the power goes up X
cubed divided by three the new power
okay and then this guy will be x squared
or two cuz you divide by the new power
so you can easily work out with
primitive years but I want to illustrate
for you using this addition property
okay how can I consider this
geometrically because every time you
look at a new object sorry from the same
object from new angles you get new
information so I can write it as two
integrals what will they they naught to
1 of x squared that's that's my F in
this case right and I can add it to this
guy not to one of X just the second
piece okay let me try and visualize this
for you so sorry let me open this up
hide some stuff okay
remote much yeah we okay don't worry too
much about my equation soup over here on
the left hand side we'll come to that in
a minute
this is x squared plus x it doesn't look
very much like x squared plus X but
that's because you can see I have
restricted the domain right if I just
take off that restriction let's do that
tada there's the rest of the parabola
right so you can see oh that's that's
what you expect because you could
factorize out and X which would leave
you with x times X plus 1 that gives you
a root at 0 and a root at negative 1 so
so far so good
ok let me put that restriction back
because this graph is going to get
really busy really fast so I only are
interested in this right-hand side okay
so you just superimpose the rest of the
parabola over there if you like if you
try to struggle with it okay now the
area that we are interested in from
naught to 1 what does it look like it
looks like no wrong one
where is it where's it going hold on
bear with me x squared + oh I see sorry
I have to change something that's better
there's the area that I'm after okay so
you can see the boundary not boundary 1
and there it is the whole thing bounded
underneath the curve so far so good yeah
well what I'm suggesting is we can break
this into two pieces right what are the
two pieces well here's y equals x that's
one of the functions in there right the
area underneath there I'm suggesting we
can add so let me just show you that
area underneath there there it is okay
that area underneath there we can add to
the area underneath what's the other
part of the function that I'm missing
I've got X already the other part is
just x squared right so I told you it's
gonna get busy really fast there's an x
squared ok so what does the area
underneath that look like ok it's too
many colors to me overlapping things ok
so what's going on well let's have a
look and see if I get rid of this guy
for you and I want to leave that one
this one okay so what I want to show you
is if I bring down this here we go ok so
what I want to show you is the whole
area which goes all the way up to here
you remember that have you got it
visually in your memory ok that whole
area here is the sum of this area which
is underneath x squared in addition to
this area this triangle does that make
sense which means that the area I've got
colored right now should be the same as
the difference between these two lines
let me show you ok watch carefully I'm
gonna move this guy if my fingers any
good and I'll move this guy upwards okay
do you see what I'm doing here I'm
trying to show the comparison between
the area under x-squared that parabola
and the area between x squared plus X
and X that's the difference right so
watch as it moves ok what's actually
happening well what I'm adding it to is
this line here do you see it are you
convinced that these are the same let me
move it again in fact I'll get it to
move itself ok so you can see when you
start with just regular x squared okay
regular x squared is underneath here
familiar parabola shape okay but as you
add X to it and as you do that sort of
gradually what happens well you're
adding nothing at this point right do
you see why I had nothing
what's the y equals x line equal to at
that point it's equal to zero so that's
why it doesn't go anywhere right over
here on the other hand you're adding a
huge amount you're adding much more
right does that make sense and in
between you're adding these increasing
amounts so that's why watch the the
curvature of the parabola do you see it
sort of curves upward right in fact
you're kind of spinning it around
because you're you're not just adding
you're not just vertically shifting
you're actually adding a different
amount each time so now I'm going to
stop it just because it weeds out my
brain too much ok
so we're saying blue area purple area
they're the same so therefore if I want
this total area adding this and adding
miss out of the same effect right so
therefore if I get rid of that purple
one and say there we go
sure enough there is the original area
you saw but now I've divided it into two
pieces
there is the underneath X part and there
is the underneath x squared part I've
just put it in the right place it
doesn't belong down here it actually
belongs up here that gives you the real
parabola you're interested in does that
make sense okay so let me put this away
these ideas here just like you had to
get used to the way differentiation
works we're now going to have to get
used to the way integration works it's a
new kind of object admittedly one of the
things the most confusing about it is
that you've spent so long
differentiating that when you have to
think wait how do I work with this
integrating again what's the primitive
our brains forget that you have to do
everything in Reverse right so that's
probably the biggest like it's like it's
literally like learn to drive in Reverse
which is not very easy okay so you will
get more confident as it with it as you
get more practice